und nun ist eingetreten meine damen und
herren was wir den ganzen nachmittag
über schon befürchteten queen elizabeth
die zweite ist tot
sie starb heute nachmittag friedlich in
balmoral
ihren
sommersitz in schottland und hier sehen
wir wieder juni in jack auf halbmast ist
bei mir im studio er ist alexander von
schönburg noch alexander
die leute die mitteilung genau das
verlasst ist die mitteilung lautet
greenpeace philippe morel des afternoon
also die königin ist friedlich in b-moll
heute nachmittag entschlafen die king
and queen konzert mit paintball moral
des evening in returned landen tomorrow
als der könig und die
königin gemahlin also camilla werden in
bayern bleiben heute abend und morgen
nach london zurückkehren
dass die offizielle mitteilung des
buckingham palastes
ein historischer einschnitt an dem wir
im weiteren müssen alexander
70 jahre war königin elizabeth auf dem
thron sie hat eine epoche geprägt wie du
gesagt hast die zweite elisabethanische
woche sozusagen sie hat uns über
jahrzehnte begleitet vom beginn der 50er
jahre bis heute all das was wir erlebt
haben wie sich unsere welt verändert hat
haben wir zusammen mit queen elizabeth
erlebt
ja es ist eine fürchterliche zäsur und
ich muss mich auch erst mal sammeln um
das um das zu begreifen
es ist ein bisschen so als ob ein
familienmitglied stirbt also was ist ja
doch jemand der uns alle geprägt hat
weil sie einfach immer da war und
einfach egal ob du monarchie ist bist
oder nicht
sie war eine konstante vielleicht eine
der letzten konstanten
dies überhaupt noch geht oder dieser
haupt noch gab
hier sehen wir im moment ihrer krönung
das war 1953 die welt 1953 war eine
andere wir sehen menschen die von
fernsehgeräten sitzen weil eben die
haushalte noch keinen noch keine
fernsehgeräte hatten das war in pro dorf
gab es vielleicht eins im pub und es gab
noch keine telefone und im internet und
kein handy und wie das leben war etwas
völlig anderes und die königin elizabeth
hat hier sehen wir ihre den tag ihrer
krönung
juni 3 153
seitdem hat sich die welt einfach wenn
man so will auf den kopf gestellt und
das wird in momenten wie diesen wirklich
klar dass mit ihr eine epoche zu ende
geht eine das mit ihrem tod eine zäsur
stattfindet eine zeitenwende und das ist
erst mal erschütternd ich finde wir
haben in mehrere zeitenwenden in den
letzten zwei jahren mitgemacht und das
ist nun wirklich der der dem
sprichwörtlich die krone aufsetzt also
ich konnte mir vor zwei jahren nicht
vorstellen dass ich zu hause eingesperrt
bin weil irgendein virus bei die
regierung mir sagt ich darf das haus
nicht verlassen die nach einem
atomschlag als das war vor zwei jahren
konnte ich es nicht fassen habe auch das
gefühl gehabt ich befinde mich in einer
historischen neuen situation der krieg
in der ukraine ist muss man sich mal
vorstellen
wir haben doch alle so gelebt dass wir
das gefühl hatten
krieg gebe es bisher kannten wird es nie
mehr geben es wird es ist wird anderer
form von von kriegen geben und und aus
diesem grunde haben wir die bundeswehr
quasi abgebaut und gesagt haben der
konventionellen krieg wird nicht mehr
statt wenn plötzlich ist das vor unserer
haustür wir haben ich glaube dass das
eine große erschütterung für uns alle
ist das königin im dass die königin
gestorben ist nicht wer sich jetzt nicht
verdient hätte wenn wir nach einem
langen langen
pflichtbewussten leben in imbissen
zeigen sich vom ausgedrückt mit ihrem
geliebten ehemann im himmel zu
vereinigen wenn man das baby das fromme
ausdrücken könnte sie hat ihre letzte
ruhe verdient sie hat ihr ganzes leben
für die pflicht gegeben
aber für uns alle ist es ein tiefer
einschnitt und ich glaube wie tief
dieser einschnitt ist das wird erst
purple uns klar werden weil eine neid
die konstante die uns den letzten 70
jahre mehr als 70 jahre begleitet hat
als
immer gleichbleibende immer stoisch
immer im
skandalfreie
ruhige hand führende königin von england
das die nicht mehr ist das wirkt für von
allen menschen als große zäsur empfunden
werden ein bisschen so wie ich das
vorhin gesagt hat als ob ein himmels
gestirn nicht mehr da ist also entweder
werden wenn wir heute abend auf die
straße gehen würden und der mond wer
plötzlich nicht da würden wir alle
fürchterlich erschrecken und so ist es
ja ein bisschen auch mit der queen 70
jahre auf dem thron im kreise ihrer
familie auf schloss balmoral friedlich
eingeschlafen heute nachmittag queen
elizabeth die zweite ist tot meine damen
und herren eine zeitreise auf die wir
sie jetzt noch mal mitnehmen
über 100 kriege und konflikte eine
pandemie mit hamsterkäufen
internet und smartphones und mittendrin
queen elizabeth die zweite eine frau die
ihr leben dem thron gab es ist der
zweite juni 1953 nach dem tod ihres
vaters george mitten im kalten krieg und
mit gerade einmal 27 jahren wird
elisabeth die zweite zur königin
großbritanniens und damit zu einer der
bedeutendsten persönlichkeiten der
letzten 70 jahre zu dieser zeit ist
georgia zum zweiten mal premierminister
ihres landes während ihrer amtszeit
erlebt sie genau 15 verschiedene
premierminister
am ersten november 1955 kommt es in
vietnam zum krieg ein krieg der die welt
bewegt und um die 20 jahre andauert am
20 juni 1961 wird john f kennedy zum
präsidenten der usa ernannt zwei jahre
später wird er bei einem attentat
ermordet mit john f kennedy lernt die
queen insgesamt in ihrer amtszeit 13 us
präsidenten kennen
am 15 juni 1961 gibt es in ost berlin
eine internationale pressekonferenz mit
dabei starts vorsitzender der ddr walter
ulbricht und einer der wahrscheinlich
berühmtesten sätze überhaupt
eine lüge der zwei monate später am 13
august 1961 wird westberlin abgeriegelt
und über nacht die berliner mauer gebaut
erst am 9 november
1989 werden die grenzen wieder geöffnet
und die berliner mauer fällt die wende
in deutschland hat begonnen
anders sieht es am 16 oktober 1962 in
kuba aus die so genannte kuba krise ist
höhepunkt des kalten krieges während
vielleicht in ihrer amtszeit passiert
kommt es aber auch zu technischen
durchbrüchen wie zum beispiel in
deutschland am 25
august 1967 mit der ersten
ausgestrahlten sendung in farbe die ehre
des farbfernsehens hat begonnen
am 21 juli 1969 landet der erste mensch
auf dem mond am dritten april
1973 wird das erste handy gespräch
geführt das internet wird erfunden und
weiterentwickelt die zeit der
digitalisierung ist in vollem gange am
26 april 1986 explodiert dann das
atomkraftwerk tschernobyl
die bisher größte katastrophe in der
geschichte der atomenergie knapp fünf
jahre später am 26 dezember 1991
zerfällt die sowjetunion am 13 februar
1996 einen tag vor valentinstag werden
millionen frauenherzen gebrochen als ich
die kult band take that trend der elfter
september 2001 auch bekannt als nine
eleven geht mit dem terroranschlag auf
das world trade center in die geschichte
ein fast 3.000 menschen kommen dabei ums
leben
am 20 märz 2003 kommt es zum krieg im
irak zwei jahre später am 22 november
2005 wird angela merkel bundeskanzlerin
in 70 jahren auf dem thron erlebt die
queen genau neun deutsche bundeskanzler
ende 2009 10 gibt es die ersten
meldungen zu corona die folgen eine
weltweite pandemie schwere
krankheitsverläufe tod angst
hamsterkäufe und demonstration gefolgt
vom brh exit am ersten januar 2020 im
land der queen die briten verlassen die
eu am 24 februar
2022 marschiert putins armee in die
ukraine ein ein weiterer krieg den die
queen in ihren 70 jahren an der könig
spitze erlebt queen elizabeth die zweite
ein leben für die krone ein leben voller
bedeutender historischer ereignisse
[Musik]